hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from complex con in Long Beach
California we're going to mix it up
today do a little fan Q&A and then we
have some super fan trivia but first I'm
joined Akashi Murakami and he really has
brought this weekend to life I just
wanted to say thank you thank you so
much but before you go do you want to
eat a wing coated in Blair's Megadeth
sauce with liquid rage oh I'm sorry so
no thank you no thank you
only probably the smartest guests that
we've ever had I know that you can't
stay but before you go would you please
take some hot ones hot sauce I'd be
honored thank you thank you it's really
nice to meet you and then now what we're
doing is this super fan trivia challenge
but we really wanted it to be
interactive for the fans at home so we
took some Twitter questions and what
we're going to do is bring in the other
half of the hot ones brain if you're a
hot ones fan you're probably
peripherally aware of Chris Schoenberger
now we're really drawing back the
curtain and what a glorious show it is
Chris has pulled some Twitter questions
from fans we're just going to answer
them get through those and then we're
going to do the super fan trivia
challenge and then I got to go because
Chief Keef is going to be playing across
the hallway and I got a VIP wristbands
so we're really going to get it going
but Chris start hitting me with some
questions quitter these are your hot
ones all right all right
I'm been known says describe the worst
experience you've had with spicy food
alright so that is far and away the time
that I ate a Carolina Reaper with chili
Klaus in the basement of jimmies 43 on
the Lower East Side the thing about New
York is there no alleys and in alleys
that's where you can do sketchy things
so I eat the world's hottest pepper at 3
o'clock in the
noon I go outside because I have to
throw up and there's no place to go I
have the campus of NYU right there
hundreds of kids walking around the
streets are packed with people and I
just have to vomit in the middle of the
street in front of an audience of a
hundred people
grossest most embarrassing humiliating
experience I've ever had with Hockfield
strong anecdote alright at David Justice
Ct who was your favorite guest and your
least favorite guest and why are both
answers DJ Khaled hot pink hot cake so
that's probably like the greatest
question ever because yeah I would not
trade that afternoon for anything in the
world at the same time though not not in
that moment probably like the most
prepared guest but the best guest ever
who would you of button
I loved your budget and I'm not gonna
apologize for it either and that's a
controversial yeah you were like the
contrast a button right now just say bud
just say button it's Joe button if
you're mad about it I don't care
all right next one from super fan Bret
Baker author we played our rankings
shout out Brett Baker he says Sean
what's your biggest beef with the power
rankings top ten
all right biggest I'd have to look at it
right now but if I think all right the
biggest beef with the power rankings top
ten is can we pull it up yeah what's
your biggest beef with the power
rankings top ten well he's got Eric
Andre Eric Andre number one right right
um I don't have a know where it is what
he loves comedians
he loves comedians that he loves weenie
tots he has a soft spot for comedians
and I think that he shades his rankings
towards comedians Bret has a very Brett
experience and he checks it from the
Brett experience and that already has an
objective rubric by which he's measuring
these people that's my one issue with
Brett okay at Kenny easy how close were
you to engaging in fisticuffs with Joe
Budden with jump on it never never and
by the way he would he is like a safety
on the Green Bay Packers compared to me
like if I ever was going to fight Joe
button that would end very poorly for me
so never I'm very I'm a coward I'm soft
I don't fight anybody I'll never ever
even close to fighting anybody all right
a few more at black badger wants to know
he says my question is a two-parter very
hot ones by the way number one why no
beer when you shoot hot ones it's better
than milk especially stout number two
best beer with spicy food so we've done
beer before riffraff cleaned a six-pack
of Corona by like the Faisal e-easy did
Burt drink beer probably before probably
probably after and then during chili
Klaus drank some beer here's the thing
I'm not really like a beer dude I'm not
like a beer guy just have some milk have
some water eat some wings just I don't
know if I love beer maybe I would if
guests wanna drink beer I don't care
it's just it's not my thing
favourite beer with spicy food I don't
know Stella Wow learning it's loud oh is
that they're not gonna sponsor you
alright Anthony Anthony buongiorno great
name
yep asks what sauce do you use when you
eat a taco bill so I thought well the
Taco Bell hot sauce is a great sauce not
the mild not be like whatever their
hottest thing is but the standard Taco
Bell hot sauce are amazing it's amazing
it's amazing it's one of the best hot
sauces I think all right last one before
these uh forming Big Jim kebabs Bilal
Khan can we please document all of the
Sean Evans hand gestures and their
meanings so alright I take so much heat
for this but here's the thing like what
I just talked I trust me I look at the
video afterwards I'm like why do I do
that it's so ridiculous and even like
right now
like trying to stop I don't know my
brain just says like words think words
and then my hands just move it's
something on a doughnut sauce and well I
don't know it's just like all right back
it up stop wait I don't know like they
all have their own meetings this is just
kind of a nervous thing but anyways
everybody just get off my dick about
it's not that big all right that's it
that's all the questions it all right
Schaumburg Schaumburg are back to your
hole no air time for another year and a
half all right so now what we're going
to do is we're going to bring up some
hot ones superfans maybe they're not
even superfans we'll expose them if
they're not maybe they just finesse
their way into a line to get free hot
sauce so what we're going to do is we're
going to ask each of them three
questions they're going to have three
wings to eat and they're going to be
coded and what do we have hot ones des
bomb and Blair's Megadeth sauce is that
right all right hot ones the bomb blares
if they make it through free hot sauce
for the first person who gets all the
questions right you get a t-shirt we
only brought one t-shirt so if a couple
people get all three right I don't know
what to tell you can't guarantee it'll
fit it is a large we got some sunglasses
we got some stickers we're just going to
cycle them through so first person are
they ready come on up my man
sir what's your name what's your
favorite episode how are you with hot
food and then my name is Tyler my
we'll find out all right do we have his
wings here we go
so you're going to want to start here I
imagine but I'm not positive I don't see
these things through like you think I
would left right thank you Sarah Honda
all right who has made it through the
fewest number of wings and hot ones
history D Jacob DJ Khaled
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding to eat your
wing it's your way good one right the
hot ones hot sauce is good ones hot
sauce is good and I think I might have
messed it up so you should probably now
I'm going to make you go back to back
wings before I ask the next question
okay
how is that pretty good right the hot
ones hot sauce so this is the bomb and
this is actually a very hot sauce so
we'll see this is kind of where you're
gonna take just one bite take one bite
take one bite so I'm gonna get the whole
way again all right now while you eat
which guests set of Ray J his [ __ ] style
is buck wild was it Matty Matheson Eddie
Wang or Michael Rapaport Michael Rapp
Michael Rapaport yeah all right
so your last wing blares Megadeth sauce
with liquid rage if you would like to
dab you can damn look
I think I did too much all right
[Music]
not including Tony Hawk who streamed at
just over a half hour yesterday what is
the longest episode of hot ones in
history is it Bert Kreischer Joe Budden
or Jay Pharoah Jay Pharoah sure it's
Bert Kreischer great job let's get a
great job you get yourself some hot ones
hot sauce my man next victim nice [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna need it
all right how you doing my man so high
there's your mic what's your name what's
your favorite episode and how are you
with hot food my name is jonathan 19
years old favorite episode has to
definitely be the Carly Aquilino
considering that she's incredibly hot
okay and with hot food I don't have good
experiences all right well this should
be another bad one this house is
definitely gonna be a bad one take a
bite out of hot ones I'll hit you with
your first trivia question all right
which country is chili Klaus from Norway
Finland or Denmark sodium which country
is chili Klaus from Norway Finland or
Denmark
I'm going straight for them sinner
it's Denmark it's Denmark everyone knows
Chile classes from Denmark not in Chile
Rosie all right you ready for number two
my friend was laughing at me right now
that was a great wing right looks pretty
good so this next one is the bomb beyond
insanity we move them quick we move them
quick take a bite take a bite learn no
more the personal trying joy how many
wings were in the first ever hot ones
challenge with Tony Yayo was it 5 7 or 9
shoot Sara how many wings in the first
ever hot ones challenge at Tony Yayo was
it 5 7 or 9 I just said 5 you can't say
5 but you'd be wrong
the answer is 7 no he's now drinking the
mug all right you ready to drink all
right and you can dab if you want you
don't have to
[Applause]
I'm literally doing I'm literally doing
this because my cousin is probably
laughing at me right now all the friends
are definitely to watch this
and and the second one is ready hot
enough and I'm just dying so that's an
interesting strategy talking about loud
come up Alexis your own experience I
would say it's a questionable one but
I'm doing this further I came to talk
for a reason for the paper every one for
you oh my god
one bite though be careful Margot a
little boy named one hot sauce from
season one that is not on season two
name one hot sauce that's on season one
but not CC - they're more hot sauce is
not instantly that's not oh oh
ah it's making me her it's making me
hurt ah I'm gonna give you a freebie
Cholula would have been acceptable Texas
gas would have been acceptable
lottie's would have been acceptable it's
definitely more on your eyes somebody
get there guys somebody get that guy
nurse good lord
good lord who's up next
who's up next hey I'm Josie nice to meet
you all right Ron han-shan there you go
what's your favorite episode I don't
know a day you don't know nothi son so
this will be interesting yeah okay and
how are you at our food um I love
hotdogs okay cool we'll see how much
we'll see how much she's never seen an
episode this is not gonna be easy yeah
it's gonna be all right try your first
one and I'm not going to help you out
we'll just see how it goes okay so take
a bite of the first wing just a bite
don't you douse it hot sauce not that
which sauce is number seven in our order
is it hot ones pain 100% or dabomb
dabomb dabomb ding ding ding ding ding
ding Wow Wow
take a bite out of the second wing now
did we take about other first one okay
oh good you like that one it's pretty
hot watch his face watch his face okay
go ahead who who's the first hot ones
guess to clear all the wings damn do I
get to have the names or not the guests
for myself Anthony Rizzo ja Rule or
b.o.b I feel like b.o.b would demolish
that but it's our rule hmm hmm that's
our question guys the fans know the fans
knows why is that like tech side no
man's dumb yeah yeah I can dance okay
but no you can't you can there's no
lifeline jawohl yeah be me I'll be Eric
Anthony Rizzo World Series champion
Anthony Rizzo
John Anthony okay so this is the last
wing if you want you can dab the last
man you don't have to if you don't want
to do it blares Megadeth's awesome
liquid red [ __ ] Devon she's dabbing yeah
okay hold on and I hope you're playing
at home and keeping score oh [ __ ]
all right a little that's smart that's
that's okay that's good all right that's
that's extends a lot is it everyone's
really going there Oh which guests
refused to give a plug opting instead to
just say I just came to eat and then he
left
was it yg David Cross Joe Budden yg and
it was Joe bunch I'm gonna jump on and
get water that's there he was just there
for the sport he was yourself in the
sport just like you but there are no
winners in this game
you get a free bottle
[Applause]
hey I need someone take some milk yeah
take a water to go Thanks
it's all there for you fine bye Wow
wasn't that bad it's just tingly all
right who's next
thank you that's good about the live
studio audience all right fan number
four yes please what's your name what's
your favorite episode and how are you
with hot food is Bobby Lee Bobby Lee
yeah great episode classic instant
classic ship so fantastic you look sick
that's why that's what makes that's the
difference
all right the first one is hot ones just
take a bite all right hot ones hot ones
guests have said that I look like all of
the following except for who so I'm
going to give you four names three of
them guests have said you look like this
person one of them they've yet to say it
I want you to figure out which okay Neil
Patrick Harris jean-luc Picard Smeagol
and Jason Statham which one have I never
been compared to on the show John Luke
Picard no that's your favorite episode
just look really oh he was uh ah damn
wow wow wow sorry number two
the answer by the way is Jason Statham
which is a ridiculous injustice because
I do look like Jason Statham it's
ridiculous you said in John lupa car you
said yourself cynical you said it
yourself though right what episode that
you look like Jason Statham I maybe say
it on Twitter every once in a while and
I did it should be said more often Jason
Statham Justin Timberlake these are the
people I look like not Smeagol jean-luc
Picard all right number two who's on the
next at this hour eat eat up eat that
way
eat that bomb who's on the next episode
of hot ones we want to make sure our
social media manager is doing their job
who's on the next episode of hot ones
well they posted on Twitter I'm not on
Twitter so I just want a sneak peak a
video that we posted but at the end that
you'd only know if you were really
waist-deep in this I don't know I'm
sorry yeah the answer Action Bronson
Action Bronson alright one last one
blares Megadeth sauce with nickel enrage
you got to take that dab gotta take that
damn so this one Chris Schoenberger
double check my math in case I screwed
this up okay what is the Scoville rating
did you take a bite oh no oh that's a
that the gun the down here stressing me
out everyone here's a legal liability
take a bite
take the bite everyone oh man all right
what's the Scoville rating of our hot
sauce is that fifteen thousand six
hundred twelve thousand six hundred or
twenty five thousand six hundred fifteen
thousand thousand six hundred that's
gonna get you a couple hours yeah thank
you
and then we have one last fan one last
fan last but not least how you doing hi
what's your name
Julia Julia was your favorite are you
Sean I'm Kai I'm John nice to meet you
um can I say I haven't watched the show
right now so no one gets mad good lord
all right one producer is really
knocking it out of the park in this
lineup
oh wait am i lik feel like this thing
just uh just just here I'll walk you
through this I'm very shaman like just
take that first bite of that first wing
right there I'll ask you a question that
you probably won't be able to answer but
let's see no yeah I got this who is the
first hot ones guest to ever dabble wing
was it Machine Gun Kelly gunplay or
Prince Amukamara um eh
Machine Gun Kelly it was machine gun
[ __ ] I was the show he's badass so
number two is the bomb
beyond insanity wait hold on go ahead
you might not have seen the show but you
get it you get what's going on under
this who is the who's the only hot ones
guest ever attempt the challenge in
Reverse was a Carly Aquilino huh
riff-raff or Eddie Wang we're out
hey I was Eddie Eddie gonna guess it was
happy when he went hottest first you
went hottest first not hottest last we
go hottest last damn if you'd like
everybody dabbing like what I think it's
I think this is good because I feel like
everybody else is kind of like doing a
coffee so really standard that one got a
university that's okay that's okay just
just swab that it's well on there I'm
scared
so this one their last trivia question
very topical very topical which hot ones
guest was ejected which hot ones guest
was ejected from an NFL game today for
throwing a tantrum and then tossing his
towel at a ref was at Prince Amukamara
Rob Gronkowski or Travis Kelce B it was
not Rob Gronkowski it was Travis Kelce
but there's no
alright so if you're playing at home if
you're playing at home tally your number
I would say like we kind of ordered it
so it's like the first questions a
little bit easier second question a
little bit harder than third question so
maybe you know give yourself one point
for the first two for the second three
for the third see how you did and I want
to say thank you to the hot ones fans
for rocking with us and for watching
with us and growing with us hope you
enjoyed it and come to Complex Con next
year if you weren't happy with this one
if you're like no I can bring it come to
Complex con next year grab the seat
we'll get it going again thank you very
much I'm off to Chief Keef
[Applause]